you and your wife don't sing what you
seem pretty hands-on with those kids we
have four kids are you gonna have a fit
probably Jesus look at you like nothing
bothers you yeah that's something to
spend your money on I always talk to my
wife I got nothing bob is that Alec
Baldwin nothing he just Tina he does
catch up to you it does catch up I do
walk in the kitchen every morning now
and and my sons my son Leo who's blond
and blue-eyed he's very like I'm
thinking you know he who's his father so
and he's like 28 yeah he's three years
old boys you ever see boys who have that
Tarzan body yeah because they don't they
just burn up so many calories but also
they just have that kind of physiognomy
where they're very muscular when they my
son Leo's like Tarzan right and he's
running around what am I gonna do you're
gonna drop him in the jungle and then
I'm gonna go live there which game I am
I'm 62 years old in April and I got four
little kids I don't know do you ever do
the math you ever sit there and go you
know look maybe I'll live a long life
maybe I'll live till I'm 90 and that'll
be but that'll work maybe not maybe not
but it's just like what the [ __ ] oh my
friend said I'm gonna be at their
commencement exercise for them they
graduate from college and be like what
they call his name